con flores y minutos de silencio así es
cómo se conmemoraron las vidas de las
130 víctimas mortales que dejaron los
ataques de parís en noviembre de 2015 en
el sexto aniversario de los atentados
terroristas a los actos conmemorativos
asistieron el primer ministro sanz
castex el ministro de interior llega al
dagma na y la alcaldesa de parís anne
hidalgo françois hollande quien ejercía
el cargo de presidente en ese entonces
se pronunció a través de su cuenta de
twitter este 13 de noviembre pienso en
todas las víctimas de los terribles
atentados que asolaron a nuestro país
hace seis años pienso en sus seres
queridos que están sufriendo y en todos
los supervivientes que con el juicio
para juzgar a los responsables obtendrán
justicia
de hecho hollande es uno de los testigos
en el histórico juicio en parís que
cuenta con 20 acusados incluido el
principal sospechoso sala abdeslam por
su participación en el asalto yihadista
sin embargo seis de ellos son juzgados
en ausencia entre tanto los
supervivientes esperan que se haga
justicia o construcción sea como equipo
no existe es un momento clave para
nosotros y lo que se diga durante el
juicio lo que digan los magistrados los
acusados y los demás demandantes quedará
grabado en piedra
así que este año es importante
asimilarlo todo y marcar la ocasión
el 13 de noviembre de 2015 grupos de
hombres armados y terroristas suicidas
atacaron el perímetro del estadio
deportivo stat de france la sala de
conciertos del bataclán y una serie de
bares y cafés un ataque reivindicado por
el estado islámico debido a la
participación de francia en la lucha
contra ellos en irak y siria
[Música]